il
décerné des médailles pour rappeler
l'attachement de la réunion à ces
soldats du feu c'est dans le cadre de la
journée nationale des sapeurs-pompiers
que cette cérémonie officielle s'est
déroulée en présence du préfet de la
présidente du conseil départemental et
du maire de saint-andré réunionnais
formidable car nous aimons l'aude il
nous a aidés par quentin 23 sapeurs
pompiers ont reçu le diplôme de
formation de détachement et
d'intégration les diplômes qui
récompense pour certains d'entre eux
plus de vingt ans d'engagement au sens
du service départemental d'incendié et
de secours
22 agents sapeurs pompiers
professionnels et volontaires ainsi que
des personnels administratifs ont reçu
la médaille de la reconnaissance
fédérale médaille en elle même n'est pas
la fidélité
mais on fait ce métier parce qu'on a
envie de rendre service et la
reconnaissance au quotidien des gens à
qui il a rendu service ça c'est le plus
beau cadeau non seulement des sondes
avait eu également des protecteurs de la
vie et ses symboles a plus d'un comprend
la police et les deux il ya trois
sapeurs pompiers se sont vu remettre la
médaille de bronze pour acte de courage
et de dévouement
le sergent-chef le revendeur bel air et
le caporal chef ludovic gauthier sont
distingués lors d'une opération de
sauvetage en mer en portant secours au
péril de leur vie à des plongeurs en
difficulté d'abord ça rend fier et ça me
rend extrêmement joyeux d'avoir reçu
cette médaille
le caporal chef pascal robert sapeurs
pompiers volontaires du centre de
secours de saint benoît a été blessé en
tentant de mettre fin à une agression à
main armée en s'interposant entre
l'agresseur et la victime
sauf que ça peut toujours plaisir
voilà qui aurait pu même chose moi parce
que bon ben lamb et annuler l'entente et
à venir les aider les gens sauver les
gens de l'ocha c'était évident est
évident c'est évident voilà le public ne
connaît pas forcément tous qui tout ce
qui se cache derrière toutes les
spécialités puisqu'il se prépare et
notamment cette jeunesse qu'on a vu à
travers les jeunes ça bon pied donc
c'est un moment de rencontre avec la
population et on profite d'ailleurs de
ce moment pour mettre en exergue aussi
les qualités les pompiers et puis pour
certains des faits héroïques car je
crois qu'on peut employer le terme
décoration et des médaille pour acte de
courage et de dévouement
une journée nationale qui a été aussi
l'occasion de montrer toutes les
missions et les différents corps de
métiers qui composent le 19 16 4 et
réunionnais sont venus nombreux assister
aux démonstrations au défilé final des
troupes à pied et motorisées
quand je serai grand je serai pompier
les hommes du feu non core soucis à ce
faire la relève est d'ores et déjà
assurée